holy moly we are back forget hotel rooms
forget kitchens forget doorbells and you
haven't heard I came in today and I said
I'm gonna go from Samuel L and Charles
Barkley two cents so I don't that's
relevant
I don't know I'm here for relevancy
Charles Barkley apparently told me he
listens to Simms or watches Simms a love
Co that was cool yeah that's good he's a
good liar
how was your Thanksgiving it was very
good yeah I love Thanksgiving you hosted
it hosted it drank a lot of tequila so
did I yeah Vegas smoked a lot of daddy
cigars nice yes was a good day sure it
was a big Phil and joy yeah he got he
got there I would say I paused the
Cowboys rescue in the game yes so wait
for him to get to the house yes it was
nice of me and then we got there and
started watching yeah that's good he got
there I'm gonna say you got there like
5:40 you guys are parked in front of the
television yeah for a little bit
certainly eat a plate come back ate it
while watching yeah no no no we eat down
and had like we sat down at the table
yeah yeah no no sitting at the TV for
the Thanksgiving and then how much of
your family actually watches the games
with you everybody really I mean you
know the kids are in and out but
everybody's kind of sitting around the
TV semi paying attention like you know
my mom and my wife are looking up
occasionally and giggling on their own
stories or whatever yeah I was in the
MGM sitting next to Pat Perez and Darren
Clarke as they achieved some cigs and
some cigars and I'm sitting there going
come on plus seven and a half let's go
oh gosh yeah all those games well I'll
tell you what I am creating a new
segment because it's someone that look
we gamble on every game with in a way so
we're very well aware of the Sprint yeah
I'm watching the game differently than
everybody else
so coming out later I'm gonna do what am
i calling it left goes left goes big
gambles or something like that where I'm
just looking at how great moments in
gambling with Adam left go great
delivery there I killed it five moments
from Sunday and Thursday that were
really big for gamblers all right I like
that that other people weren't aware of
yeah because I'm sitting there on
day going come on Patriots hold the Jets
don't let them in where's everybody else
is going why are they trying so hard so
we'll do great moments in gambling well
oh I have a story oh never I told on the
podcast yeah Monday flying in I'm
watching Chiefs Rams on the flight yeah
okay right the guy next to me right
took your socks off his shoes off but
the dip in and he's watching my screen
right Friday of the match yeah that
morning I'm there early production
meeting I walk out to get a banana and
there's Tiger Woods sitting there two
feet away from me and I look up and I go
I put the game on his own team but I
hold I didn't know who this guy was so I
go to somebody else and I go who is that
they go that's Tigers agent and I was
like that's Tigers agent we're getting
ready to I think it's Mark Steinberg I
have to reach out to this guy I got to
meet him but I haven't talked to him but
he comes on set and Charles like hey
mark I do him good to meet she's good to
see man Samuel Jackson's like hey man
good to see you again and he and he
looks at me he goes I said next to the
plane I was like yes we did I never
thought I was gonna see this guy again
and instead it's Tigers freaking agent
yeah that was pretty awesome
it's pretty awesome I'd like to hear
more stories about you and Samuel L and
Charles Barkley okay yes I'll start off
like the two cool black guys in you yes
and Pat and Pat Perez was awesome we
were having a good time
dude I was there for like 10 yeah it was
a long time I would just say I turned it
off when Tiger was walking up to the
first day that's when you were like well
it was cutting off I was on you I was on
the youtube link at that point God sent
me the youtube link so I started
watching the breaking right and yes at
that time I was like you know what I got
to go work out yeah I need to do
something for your one day of your
routines right right so I'll say this I
wish that everyone could have heard us
for the entire match because Charles and
Sam or the funniest people I have ever
heard and then Pat and Charles have this
relationship where they just egg each
other on and Charles be like man you
better cut that damn hair and that's
like you better lose some damn weight so
like that's going on while I'm watching
the match and both of those guys would
leave occasionally and it would just be
me and Sam sitting there and Sam
golf like this man is obsessed with golf
he plays every day sometimes more than
one times a day if he took money off
somebody and they want to keep playing
them and we're just shooting the [ __ ]
the entire time and very early on he
looks at me and when Sam Samuel Jackson
looks in your eyes it's like a religious
experience say what again [ __ ]
all of those lines I just want to say
that right snakes on those but I haven't
played like it you're just there and
you're like I've seen you my whole life
yeah and he looks over me Tiger misses a
putt on like third or fourth hole yeah
and he turns to me and he goes I don't
know who these [ __ ] are but it
sure is [ __ ] tiger and Phil he's
gonna [ __ ] suck and I was like oh my
god I was like Sam I want you to say
this on TV saying I can't but we're just
going back Charles is over here betting
on college football game great healthy
numbers right
Pat's over here FaceTime and with jordan
Spieth and giving it to Barkley and
Barclays like because he Barkley said
that Jordan species just shave his head
and go bald and just admit that he's
losing his hair and it was Jordan
Spieth's wedding day and Barclays like I
didn't know Jordan it was your wedding
day my bad I mean you still guys cut
your head but the upside he doesn't
because um you know in Verlander's like
going back and forth with berkeley for
me there was a moment where i didn't
realize that when it went to the extra
holes ernie and the other broadcasters
were gonna come up to the desk we were
at and what they were going to do I
didn't really find out until mmm 45
seconds beforehand was Adams gonna do
highlights blind
oh and then also leave the set while I'm
doing highlights while Ernie comes on
are you kidding me so they're going czar
you walking around and so I'm like
picking up my paperwork yeah but also
going and then we pick it up on the 16th
hole that birdie putt there for Tiger
unable to get it down and if that wasn't
enough Charles has written on my notes
his phone number because he wants to
hang out after the match and get some
drinks right so he writes his phone
number down and he wants to make sure
that I see it me yeah 17th hole another
opportunity here but what a chip from
Tiger Woods and Charles is over here
going and I'm going and I'm going yeah
but I'm going like 18th hole we pick it
up now go I got it right and then
Charles is still tried at the paper and
eventually had to go big shot there by
Phil Mickelson and like Charles like
awesome Adam will hit me up will hang
out and I was like Charles like and I
didn't even know that was gonna happen
let me to go a little step further yeah
so I get done I go over all the
technical people like dude way to handle
that that was crazy I say yeah
absolutely they said give us the
microphone and take off your I FPS and I
said you know what can I actually keep
the I FBS on I FB is the thing in
people's ears where you can hear the
broadcast I said it stand for hopefully
Nick can answer that interrupted fall
back I don't know I was gonna say like
inter fibula later into into I was
interrupted fold back fold back okay
that's actually I didn't know that so I
said can I keep him my ears because I'm
gonna go on the course but I'd still
like to listen to the broadcaster's to
know what's going on yeah sure
so I go out there I'm hanging out with
Omar house of highlights Omar and we're
talking about how crazy this is it's
dark it's under the lights they're in a
chip off this is crazy
and right when there was the big moment
on 21 where Tiger was gonna the putt
from four feet and because there were
shadows it was dark out none of them
could hit their putts and Phil goes I
don't want to win like this pick it up
let's play 22 and it was a great moment
right when he said that the producer
gets in the headset and goes so what
we're gonna have to do is when this ends
Ernie's gonna go do the award ceremony
and Adams gonna go and and host the rest
of the postgame show oh my said now
you're gonna have to go back to the desk
so the only reason I even heard is
because I decided to keep my things in
so I run back up there and I go I'm
going back on soon and they're going
what I know I'm going back on soon so
they put it down in my shirt I grab a
microphone and as soon as already goes
on there I just jump on the set and like
Peter Jake
looks at me like what's up brother good
to see ya and I just did the postgame
show and tossed so honestly I love that
[ __ ] like that's the best yeah
because for me I've always said to
people if I could do an hour and a half
of Sims and get done and we look at each
other and go I could have done an hour
and a half more right live TV nothing
it's just it's fun it's just you know
can you look at Samuel L in the face
when he doesn't laugh at one of your
jokes and still have the balls to make
another going yeah but dude it was it
was awesome yeah that's pretty cool and
then I didn't realize I was hosting the
VIP later it was all one-on-one with me
tiger and Phil right and I had already
had some drinks we had a really good
time good tiger made eye contact and
said I kind of like that which I think
means oh that's a big victory right big
victory yeah I mean you know the only
thing that beats that I think it's like
a fist pump like true fist like I made
the big putt on 18 like that's what you
know you really did that special but it
was it was really really cool yeah
that's good you're on Sunday Night
Football
yeah big weekend for us and you got your
name on the graph I'm big time yeah now
you're four and oh I am for now everyone
else so there's like seven and five are
they I don't even know what their
records their average yeah Rob yeah but
now you're four enough or no got
something to live up to the only problem
is right man did I kick your ass in the
beds I bet I don't feel like I can want
to know or should we save it for
Thursday I mean you can give a brief
rundown right now go ahead uh I feel
like I didn't win any of my big games of
the spreads I mean I went six and one in
the one o'clock okay so all of the the
Ravens cover in the 10 1/2 the Patriots
all that right I think I'm up nine
hundred dollars in one week damn so I
love like I lost every game against the
spread yeah then you love me on all
three yeah I know you didn't you got
Chicago but you lost no I bet I thought
I picked the Lions to cover know you've
picked my so much I picked up push but
then you went with the Bears I think
you're right yeah but we'll get into
that more on the betting show that comes
out Friday s LFL update I think Timo del
Rodgers is going to the playoffs I know
that our playoffs are different rules
but that starts this week so
we got Tyreke he'll back hopefully him
and Odell and juju are ready to carry us
again but I think we're going the
playoffs okay and again the birdies are
true oh the birdies let me just say that
a few of the people that were on the set
for the match are helping build our set
in Atlanta ooh
Charles and Samuel are coming down to
build it I don't know if they're gonna
be building but I'm just saying again
you don't need to get a ticket to the
Super Bowl but that whole week we're
gonna have a lot of opportunities to see
us interacting with NFL players you're
gonna be able to hang out with us we
really want to see you guys be there so
it's gonna be awesome we're gonna have a
really good time first reaction I had it
here first it was gonna be Nathaniel
Hackett gets fired mm-hmm but now
there's two big notes
I am Nathaniel Hackett fired and Blake
bortles benched for Indianapolis number
71 Cody Kessler whoa we'll be taking
over yeah which one do you want to react
to first I guess let's just do
chronological order let's go to Daniel
Hackett right right before we go into
the obvious which is the no duh right I
will say that the guy whose book I
referenced a lot preseason Warren Sharpe
yeah about a week ago put a threat
online about how repetitive Nathaniel
Hackett's play calling has been right
against Pittsburgh in the five games
where they were trying to waste the lead
the waste the time when they had the
lead they ran the same play from the
same formation four or five series in a
row on first down right he way doesn't
complain about that when they were
running it up the middle though for 10
yards that carry in the first half I
just wanted to point that out for sure
for sure but he did find a lot of trends
that when Nathaniel Hackett played
certain formations it was a hundred
percent a run or a hundred percent of
pass and his whole thing is just they
got very predictable Lefko I'm just
telling you outside no but let's just
have the contra mean you haven't forget
sit there and watch Jaguars games and I
can sit there and you're there too now
in this point where you go watch this
they're gonna do this watch this they're
gonna throw their yeah I mean we know
yeah it's not because Nathaniel Hackett
only has those plays in his paw
his playbook I mean this is the third
one feel comfortable right exactly right
I mean Greg Olson couldn't run the
three-step drop pass game at all because
Blake bortles was a below 50 pretty was
the worst three-step drop back passer in
football so your hand account that way
Jed fish he got out the door so hey as
much as you want to say it's predictable
he's also being predictable because
there's only a few amount of place that
his quarterback really feels comfortable
executing so the NFL posted a picture of
Nathaniel Hackett saying that Jaguars
have fired Nathaniel Hackett and Deion
Sanders wrote underneath my nephew six
years old saw this coming how about you
address the real issue and stop firing
innocent people and I would say we echod
those echo those comments I think that's
one of the first things we said to each
other this morning in our morning
meeting
so I guess my issue with the whole thing
with bortles and Nathaniel Hackett is
now I'm seeing everyone going bordel
sticks I know it's a weird feeling it is
weird it is because I want everyone get
no joy out of it anymore like I'm like
no crap oh man I'm like I'm like you're
finally realizing it that's what I want
to say God what everyone understand that
like we'll be in meetings for the show
Wednesdays at 8:00 p.m. and you will go
you know what I don't I know it's a big
news for everybody else but Sims doesn't
want to harp on this we don't really
want to keep pounding this like we are
actively having to tell people that we
can't talk about this this much yes
because we feel bad right but at the
same point to see everybody else talking
about it like I'm almost positive that I
went but if I went back into NFL Network
I could find dion sanders saying that
blake bortles is a winner like I'm
almost positive that I could find that
that I could find all of these NFL
analyst making excuses around making
excuses and telling me that he's a
winner and that you know he goes out
there and the team rides and dies with
him like so in a weird way I'm seeing
all of this now and I really just want
to give everybody the double bird yeah
and be like you can't be angry at Blake
bortles now it's not like portals
the problem is is like too many girls
continue to put him out there and do
this damn like I don't even want to have
this conversation because I feel like
our listeners have heard this so many
times I agree I know it's it's we're
beating and beating it to death it's
again yeah it's just I don't know what
else to say other than okay how many
offensive coordinators is this is this
three or four in the Blake bortles era
that we've gone through at some point we
just have to address the elephant in the
room that's 25,000 pounds and that's
Blake bortles you know I have a hard
time thinking that Doug Marrone wanted
to fire a Nathaniel Hackett yeah what do
you think happened I just I feel like
they have a very good relationship I
mean they go back to their Syracuse days
together
I did not realize so this is something
there and Doug Marrone I don't think is
that type of guy I think Doug Marrone
realistically knows what the issues are
there he's very pragmatic usually so I
am you so don't worry Nathaniel Hackett
said he was shocked right I feel like
somebody forced the hand that's what I
would think and whether that's a
Caldwell or a Coughlin or the owner
whoever it may be that would just be me
I don't know any of that for sure I'm
just saying that I was reading a
newspaper article today either from
Buffalo or Jacksonville yeah and
apparently Tom Coughlin's was coming
down in an elevator and it was going too
slow and he couldn't get on it was like
the official like workers elevator right
and he took a public elevator and the
writer was near him the entire time
and just heard Buffalo Bills fans
[ __ ] on Blake bortles to him for the
entire walk and the writer was like
Coughlin was furious and was trying to
get out of there as quickly as he can
and I'm almost like man did Coughlin
just sit with that for that long and go
I'm making changes I can blow guy
yelling at me is all I needed to hear
but it's it's time I don't know what
they're gonna do he's got a lot of money
left on that contract let me pull it up
really quick I just see if they're like
oh I think they're stuck with Blake for
another year I don't think they can get
out of it easy so if you want me to look
it up I will Blake bortles is the number
one trending player on spot track right
now people are trying to see us out
right so really good-looking right now
and I'll talk that they cut him next
year yes
16 and a half million dollars dead cash
so he's coming back he's coming here
after
that it's fine it's fine they'll eat
that right no it's five that's five Oh
which is still a good amount yeah
but sixteen and a half next year if they
cut him Wow yeah twenty six and a half
they cut it's gonna be you know they're
gonna be in a weird spot what happened
to boils this year is he got exposed I
mean officially not only you know the
big thing is last year they were the
number one run offense in football and
because of that and because everybody's
fear of them just mashing the line of
scrimmage and fournette coming downhill
and getting four and five yards a pop
even when there was nothing there he's
still getting three and four yards you
know that's where we saw Blake bortles
flourish flourish for a little while
because of what we talked about screen
game bootlegs shallow crosses crosses a
little deeper than the shallow crosses
because they go off the play-action
everybody's so worried about it so then
when fournette got hurt the old line
gets a little banged up all the sudden
two became okay wait we we have to throw
a little bit we're paying this guy 18
million dollars a year we have to do
this to win the football games and it
just it's just not capable of happening
and yeah I mean it's gonna be
interesting it's it's also everything I
know from leak circles he's one of the
leading issues for the team dysfunction
down there and Jacksonville you know I
told you that I'm comfortable saying it
here now you are yeah but are you
comfortable saying I'm just comfortable
saying that I have enough knowledge to
know that some of the issues we've heard
about in the locker room and things like
that this year or cuz the defense it
realizes the offense is crap and that
bortles is crap and they have a problem
with it and they know they can't talk
about it or say anything and they're
trying to be good soldiers about it but
yeah I think that's a big part of this
dysfunction and frustration in
Jacksonville when I watched Jaguars
Texans yeah
and Cody Kessler came in the game right
it went right after doing nothing all
game drove down the field this will be
very good for the Jacksonville locker
room I think yeah but you could tell the
frustrations the fight with Leonard
Burnett and Shaq lost I was unreal
yesterday I mean the Jaguars have so
much pent-up anger
yeah that I would bet a lot of it stems
from that and they spent all offseason
defending this guy well when you go onto
a field as a football player
you can walk off a field and go should
we worry the better team where we not
and I you know Jacksonville is you and I
both talked about mean they got studs
everywhere yeah they're walking off the
field is probably on a weekly basis gun
doc those guys we just played are
because good as us we lost again had to
have left the Pittsburgh game and going
we kicked their ass for three quarters
right and we lost that game right so I
Texans game that you just referred to
same thing I mean you don't take any joy
in this I don't your your own I would
say over it I would say you're also
angry though that Nathaniel Hackett had
to take the fall for it I you does
bother me because his predictable miss
that everybody is going to talk about
was because he was backed into a corner
with a quarterback that could only throw
and execute a few plays it may have been
correlation because bordel stunk so we
had to be that predictable I think so
but you know I one thing that I
appreciate about watching you rise in
broadcasting and seeing your name on the
[ __ ] graphic it's the reason I
commented on Sims aleph go give this man
some damn respect thank you is because
when you watch the game and you talk
about it a lot I know that we're not
crazy and we've had a lot of people that
have been ride-or-die with us from the
beginning
yeah and they know that the bordel stuff
was not a gimmick that just because
something becomes popular doesn't mean
it was made in an attempt to be pop
right that we would sit there and watch
the game and go no Rodgers is the best
quarterback and bortles is the worst and
people wanted to fight us on both of
those things so to watch you now rise up
and to see things like this to prove to
us that all those conversations weren't
crazy it doesn't give me joy it's more
like a relief yeah I'm happy it's done
right we don't gotta fight this anymore
fights and at the same point yet again
we weren't frickin wrong our gambling
may be wrong because gambling is hard
our game predictions are gonna be wrong
because it's hard by the way you went
five and own guaranteed to lose thank
you you're back silver lining but you
know bigger statements like quarterback
play I'm just
tired of getting into arguments with
people that are not qualified to have
the arguments with yeah I know I'm just
[ __ ] done yeah so I'm happier this is
over yeah because it was the thing where
whenever there was Blake news me and
Josh would put at the top of the rundown
because it's what our show was about but
now I don't got to talk about it anymore
no the Blake bortles era is over it was
marginally interesting when it happened
it wasn't fun yeah even though being a
Leba [ __ ] was kind of fun yeah that was
a blast you just gotta figure out who
your new number so it was fascinating
for a while it was fascinating cuz they
were winning that's what was fascinating
dude a few weeks ago people were saying
you were just a hater a few weeks ago
this season I'm sure I know I mean it's
again it just it was a great point to
show that it's a team sport and that at
the quarterback position if you have a
great team around you you don't have to
be great your team can still win we can
make this better though yeah I doubt
he'd accept but I know that you and your
dad and your brother yeah the number one
thing that they're doing what's the name
of the company that your brother and
your dad are starting damn I can't you
want to say it no it's yeah we could say
they seems complete cubillas complete
could be complete could be a yes isn't
it yeah I think you're right yes but you
guys are working with a lot of
quarterbacks yeah some in the NFL yeah
some in college and it's just about
helping throwing motion and you would
love to work with Blake bortles I'd love
to
I've said it before and I'll say it
again hey no he might hate me and damned
if he comes up and wants to work with
the simsimi I might even let him punch
me one time might just go ahead go ahead
give but really but you just want to
have him up here and just work on
mechanics we could certainly show him
some things that could certainly help
him throwing the football no doubt you
can say what you want about the Sims
family whether we're good quarterbacks
or not there was probably only one good
of a good one and that's Phil but we
could all throw the ball and I think
anybody saw some person throw the ball
you go damn I didn't realize you guys
were that talented and we're yeah we're
nuanced about it we love it we live it
we talk about it all the time and that's
what we did you would love to work out
with him if possible yeah you'd be
interested we would definitely dude come
up we'll drink some Bert we'll drink
some tequila right we'll smoke some
daddy cigars go out there and throw the
pigskin right they'll be great throw the
pigskin and then yeah
laughter a little off that's the key
needs I did realize though I was looking
up earlier there is one statistic yeah
that connects Blake bortles and Phil
Simms both had 13 career pick sixes is
that right yeah Blake did in five Phil
did 15 15 15 and so did Brady Brady's
got 13 - no that's unreal damn
dad threw one in 93 I can remember that
was his last pick six bills games Sunday
Night Football
did you ever throw a pick six what yes
either a few college in pros man damn
okay yeah pick six all right Giants
Eagles yeah you watch the film i watch
the film both sides all right so I want
to say the first part of the
conversation is that Odell came out and
said knowing that the Eagles were
struggling with injuries in the
secondary personally I would have loved
to attack them but that wasn't in our
game plan so I went through and I'm
seeing everyone on TV talking about how
sake one didn't get the ball enough in
the second half and that blah blah well
I looked so let me just give a few steps
before you know cuz I looked at every
possession gotcha
in the first half the Giants had the
ball for 17 minutes they controlled the
clock they had 15 first downs the Eagles
only had the ball for 13 minutes and
eight first downs so Giants had the ball
they were moving it's a Kwan at nearly
100 in the second half the Giants only
had the ball for 10 minutes right and
had three first downs part of the issue
with the Giants defense I thought was
the offense was three and out three and
out three and out I mean out it was
crazy right
and the it wasn't like the Eagles had
these long drives they only had one
drive of longer than five minutes it was
the game-winning drive when they were
kind of milking the clock right so when
I looked at all the possessions
I saw sake went up the middle for three
sack for 11 yards say Quan middle draw
pun then five plays of all Wayne Gulman
on the field which I agree with Giants
fans
Wayne Gulman should not be getting an
entire Drive to himself yeah
then like one deep pass to Odell in
which it wasn't even near him at the end
of the third quarter and the fourth
quarter was incomplete sack punt and
then they had that one drive where I
will admit as an Eagles fan Odell was a
hundred percent how in the end that was
a pass interference but I'm curious when
you looked at the whole game yeah was
Odell right when you watch the film were
there opportunities for more deep shots
against a very crappy injury secondary
for the Eagles yeah it's amazing than no
names okay I don't think my take is
gonna be a lot different than what some
of the things you just said okay first
of all let me just I'll write real
quickly what I wrote about the second
half and when we'll get into the first
half and what they did I mean I wrote
the first thing I wrote about the second
half Giants came out in the second half
with same game plan you know why cuz it
[ __ ] worked in the first half you
know what I mean so they weren't gonna
change it just go and what was it damn
we dominated everything pounds was sake
well it was it was really pound was sake
want some undisciplined run Fitz buy
your defense you guys don't believe in
setting the edge or doing stuff like
that or like filling backside cutback
lanes or anything like that but yes
there was that okay so it was all sake
want early on I would say the big issue
with the second half would not be about
missed opportunities in the pass game
but more that yes say Quon didn't get
the ball more he was the MVP of the
first half so that does not make sense
to me but also when I say get the ball
more do you mean like that Wayne Gulman
series I mean is a trireme or run on
every drive yeah I mean so but so there
was context that matters to what
happened - so the first drive of the
second half hey there's a big sack he
gets sacked he lost a lot of yards so
there they are right away it was like
third in 19 or second in 19 dozer it was
30 there's like third and third and 18
right and and when the Giants are in
third and 18 they just give up yeah they
give up right and would let's listen
there's a lot of teams that do so
there's nothing wrong with that they're
not gonna play that game they don't
trust you lie okay the second drive they
come back they got a huge complete
completion to Corey Coleman he's gonna
catch a slam route and a big penalty and
it was actually a drop on this one he
dropped this one so this is a big drop
by Coleman on the second drive so I
don't know if anything changed a whole
lot in the second half from what the
Giants
approach I don't think anything I think
the Eagles you guys were played harder
and better up front you want a few more
of those battles change uncle said you
since we were in there Jenkins said they
went to the locker room and simplified
the defense I would say so you guys
definitely played a few more snaps
Amanda man didn't try to be cute just
let your front for pin their ear back to
me open again got some Jernigan that did
really well I mean of course Michael
Bennett had a few moments and Fletcher
Cox always does so I think that was the
biggest one but Barkley not getting the
ball in the second half
you know Leblanc getting away with not
one holding penalty but two I mean there
was one there was one of the earlier in
the fourth quarter where sterling
Shepherd went a slant right off a little
play-action pass I mean it's gonna be a
20 yard gain and he held sterling
Shepherd just like he hallowed L was
very similar type of thing I'm an Eagles
fan was human the refs were really been
yeah it did not help but overall yeah I
don't agree with the take of Odell
Beckham jr. on that one you know they
came out with a game plan at work the
second half didn't go as planned I
thought you'll I'm anning really was
pretty aggressive and his
decision-making for Eli Manning about as
aggressive as he can be okay and you
know when then the matchups were there
to be had with Odell date for the most
part took him there was maybe one or two
plays or I was like why are you trying
to throw it a Benny Fowler over here I
went Odell's one-on-one over here well
that was my issue is when I just look at
the play log and I see the second drive
of the second half yeah
Wayne Gulman is in for five snap right
and the main target is Corey Clement or
Corey Coleman guys say Kwan is 22 he
does not need to sit out an entire
series and also if you're gonna look for
Corey Coleman you might as well put
Odell Beckham at that spine oh we're at
a point with this offense where if it's
not going to those two guys sterling
Shepherd or Evan Engram the place should
not be being run i I hear you you have
three stott you have two and a half
stars they do their best those guys are
gonna have to come out of the game
sometime take one okay let me ask you
this yeah he runs right they pass Eli
gets sacked ray draw play he goes on the
sideline Eagles then take like a 3-4
minute drive and drive down you're
telling me after halftime
yeah and running to plays we need to sit
say Quan ya know I know every with that
you're right and let me just tell you
something
Wayne Gulman is not the guy he's okay
but like we're get we're taking away
snaps from say Kwan for what reason
yeah for what reason I mean you could I
get you I get you more touches there's
no there's no difference I'm for an
entire series the point is that you I
mean that not not that Odell was right
Odell I don't think he's right with his
take about what they did in the second
half it's the fact that what you're
saying more than anything that say Quon
didn't get the ball more was not
featured more he was obviously a
mismatch problem he was having a
phenomenal day and finding cut back
leaves he was analyst bouncing outside I
mean so you run him in the middle every
run in the second half pretty much yeah
I mean it is
I don't know I there's no other way I
can defend it either way I do it again
Pat Shermer said afterwards look we got
messed up by some penalties yeah and by
two sacks right and everyone said yeah
right that's exactly that you know the
NFL when you're not a good team those
things matter like you can't overcome
them not everybody's Drew Brees and Sean
Payton they're Brady McDaniels you think
goals we got a cool screen that I'll get
us right back on track that's close G
bot plays G BOTS get back on track oh I
like that yeah but that was another
thing I go man at any screen to say Quan
would have me freaking out and they
didn't call any of them no they did not
I mean this to me if we just had to pick
one thing that ruined the game or
changed the game I mean you guys played
good in the second half we know that but
the interception before the half is
really where the demands of the Giants
started right there the game's 1911
you're in field goal range okay and that
was one of the worst interceptions of
the year it's about as bad at
interceptions you're gonna see from a
16-year quarterback in the NFL I mean he
had no business throwing up I know Doug
did get raked across the face yeah it
didn't matter that matter because that
was already intercept it was already
intercepted I mean Jenkins was sitting
there he was about to like you know tell
those right-field they're like I got it
I got it I mean it was all there you
know so I just I don't understand that
decision-making let alone that sacrum
Barkley was open in the flat I think it
was Barkley maybe it was Goldman
it was Barkley at 20 or
I mean he had a lot of room right so to
me that was a huge point in the football
game that really kind of you know swung
the pendulum a little bit in the eagle's
way um I'm just trying to think if
there's anything else there I mean it's
amazing with some of your secondary guys
you got some no names a corner it's
unreal I mean you're back seven is just
very underwhelming as a whole and the
Eagles season is still alive all they
have to do is beat the Washington
Redskins twice the Cowboys once and then
steal a game from the Texans and they
could be nine and seven going in the
plane it'd just be a miracle
thank God I mean you're exactly right it
just su its way if I have another person
asking me what's wrong with Carson Wentz
so like I just want to be sure are you
watching what I mean come on there's
it's every players sit back there
nobody's gonna be open just to hang in
there hang in there when somebody's
finally about to bring you back bring
you down then try to throw it in there
throw a stripe - okay I mean what he's
being asked to do on a play - play basis
it's not fair he's starting to go into
Rogers and Aaron and Russell Wilson land
right now you know the good thing I saw
was what did we see from your run game
oh gosh Adam Josh Adam is the guy he's
the guy who's good a vision by you to
see him being a possible I have my
moments you know at least the thing that
he does is he has a little explosion as
far as when he gets going you could see
his top end speed is and he's a north
and south runner and he is he does not
dance and when you guys it holds true
once again when you guys run the ball
downhill you're such a more effective
offense almost every successful run you
had was downhill all the bad ones were
East and West but yet I just can't
imagine you guys are in a bad spot when
you're an incredible stat yeah today
yeah is the first day since 1933 the
Eagles Giants rivalry is tied oh I knew
it was lost I remember here in the six
and two right and four people out there
that do not know it was never this close
no the Giants have been kicking the crap
out of the Eagles for decades
that just shows you how dominant the
Eagles have been over the Giants lately
yeah nine out of the last ten I would
say it was 18 in the last 22 right like
think about that they've won 18 of the
last 22 and now they're tied right
that's how big of a lead the Giants had
I bet you I was it's actually a fun
thing to look up I would like to know
like what the stats were my dad was
playing because that's when they it got
swung to would that defense you had
there I mean the Giants were really good
but let's I'm just trying to think I
mean man yeah the Eagles had their way
with the Giants I think that yeah but
either way it is amazing I'm also going
to say this to all fans of all teams I'm
experiencing something right now that I
didn't realize when you in a Super Bowl
every broadcaster the next season is
obsessed with talking about what's wrong
with the Super Bowl champs de throning
the Super Bowl champs let's examine the
mistakes of the Super Bowl champs so
want to tell you to all the
broadcaster's out there I'm just so
annoyed with it and it's like all these
Eagles fans are freaking out man we won
the Super Bowl I do not care
yeah and added to that way you're saying
so that's playing the Jedi Mind Tricks
in your own team right and then think
about this team that has to play you
guys they have to hear the same thing
you're playing the Super Bowl chance
fidelity so they're so your sides
getting complacent and the other teams
going we better play wood we're playing
the Super Bowl champs it's unbelievable
I mean it's just part of the human
nature of the sport what do you think
about the stories about how the Eagles
are having a hard time getting Golden
Tate involved in the I mean I agree I
was just gonna go there next I mean
first of all you know does that happen
well it's you don't have an offense for
a slot receiver there's no there's never
been like an offense for the slot
receiver why cuz it's more of like a
tight end a guy doing a slant and then
an it's just yeah you don't have no
option jerk routes like we see you know
the Rams are the Saints or the Patriots
have where you just go hey Golden Tate
we trust you to read the coverage over
the middle if it's zone and there's a
hole you sit there if a guy tries to
match you you can cross his face and run
across you have no parse out the way the
offense work does not and they really
need to add that if they want to get
Golden Tate involved that's where he
made his money with Matt Stafford he can
catch the
little 6 & 7 yard passes turn it up get
an extra 5 or 6 yards and now you got a
first down that's really the beauty of
Golden Tate and I'll say this too for
defending Philadelphia coaches and all
this Golden Tate and I'm wrong in my
evaluation of this law he's a step
slower than I feel like I remember him
with Detroit he is he's a step slower
for sure but either way it's not an
offense that is doing a good job of
featuring him in any which way either
they need to find ways for him to do
that can't always be Hertz over the
middle and though such a way if your GM
trades for him right and then your
coaching staff comes out and says it's
been hard to adjust him in yeah does
that show an issue in communication just
show a little disconnect there yes
you know because you like your GM to go
hey we're thinking about Golden Tate you
know do you feel like you can use them
they're right way or it's hey we're
gonna trade for Golden Tate cuz we just
feel like we need the improvement of the
receivers and then the coaches during
the bye we gotta go you know what we
need to add some slot Golden Tate type
of place to our offline they're really
just trying to fit them in they are just
trying to run their offense normal crap
it just seems like bad coaching to me I
it's not great right now on either side
of the ball I can't sit here in line you
know I kind of root for your Eagles to a
degree there's a lot of things that I
admire but too many repeat plays too
many simple concepts I mean even the
fourth down conversion play fourth over
the middle snaggle are I mean you got
this I'm gonna say the third time you've
run that during the game I couldn't
believe the Giants running all over it
means double-crosser with a guy going
ten yards over the middle and hooking up
then you guys run that four or five
times a game and that wasn't the same
way last year last year you had your
staple plays but you had which I think
you know I'm not trying to be the Oracle
here you and I have both seen this but
you have like six or seven plays every
game where you said that's a good game
plan play right yeah and they put that
in just for this week to [ __ ] with this
defense and do that and we're seeing
that the Colts and Frank Reich have
those plays and your Eagles don't Colts
have it every freaking I know he's a
game planner he really is a game plan
all right was there anything else from
that game I was gonna move on to sow
expand I think that was it Seahawks
Panthers Seattle goes into Carolina who
is who this year has scored a lot more
points at home Seattle in this game
it's an up and back game they get the
big time fourth and three lob at the 35
two more to tie it up at 27
the Panthers myths a 52-yard er Wilson
hits Lockett on the deep ball down the
sideline and janakowski kicked the field
goal to win 30 to 27 and Seattle is
sitting here now five games a lot of
them winnable a lot of them at home
Seattle in my mind is what is either
gonna be the five or the succeed as I
look around the NFC right now Minnesota
is gonna be one of them I think or up
for one of them Carolina
huge win for Seattle and Green Bay and I
think Green Bay's out like who else is
there
the Eagles and I don't think that
they're gonna be so I think it'd be it's
like a three-person race between
Carolina's Seattle and Minnesota
Washington still there I don't think
they're gonna make it either
I'm just writing off yeah I think Dallas
is win this division unfortunately but I
look at it and I go Carolina Seattle
Minnesota looks like Minnesota and
Seattle to me certainly does look that
way so do you want to start off with
Seattle or Carolina like a note there
first what stuck out to you the most all
right I think let's just start out with
the Carolina offense or Seattle do you
cut it's okay first of all as a complete
game okay this is gonna be my bold
statement for this game this is one of
the biggest butt-whooping of a team I've
seen lose all year the butt-whooping
they had their way with Seattle every
time I looked up it was DJ more 4:30
Curtis Samuels 4:30 a free flying
through the middle Caffrey had over a
hundred yards rushing and received they
whooped the crap out of Seattle's
defense
I mean whoop the crap out of them there
was never a point in the game where I
said oh Seattle's gonna slow them down
never except first try for Carolina
fourth and three on the 5 Cam Newton
power run doesn't get it I thought the
camera angles were bad and what he
actually did get is very close so they
didn't get the channel right then put in
added to that bad run
you're not levy on bail run he stopped
in the hole and tried to wait for a hole
it's Seattle they're too fast there's
not gonna be all
gonna put your head down and plow
through it second Carolina Drive go
through it stopped inside the five again
settles for a field goals missed a third
and short so they kick a field low so
they're there they've dominated the
first two drives there were three right
let's go to the second quarter Seahawks
get a field our drive so after all that
were three to three third drive Curtis
Samuel gets to reverse 25 yards they did
get a touchdown there but so we go in a
half time it's 1310 right it's the third
quarter though Cam Newton throws an
interception in the end zone right and
that was where I saw three red zone
trips that ended up in three points yeah
can't do that in win a game no you you
you really can't I mean okay so they're
yeah you have your your first tried
second drive you just talked about
Carolina's third drive is the worst play
of the game by McCaffrey McCaffrey got a
first down screen and got nine yards and
he should have got 59 and he got he made
the one of the dumbest cuts I saw on
Sunday I mean he ran into Bobby Wagner
and then they tried to run on a second
and didn't get it and they tried to run
it on third and again they had a Punnett
that was really one of the only stops of
the day by Seattle fourth drive of the
game yes
TD pass exactly right right down the
field
okay I mean they can't stop a stop fifth
drive inside the 10 yard line they go
kick a field goal
okay so first half I mean it is an
ass-beating and there it is and would
you say it was 13 to 10 and a half 13 to
10 and a half I mean six drive they got
first and ten from the 18 yard line
you talked about it already interception
down the middle stupid decision very
next try for Seattle is the crazy Chris
Carson let's just go yes let me know on
Carolina's often just saying oh yeah
okay okay get the ball next now it's
1713 Seattle right so after all this
they're down having moved the ball at
will between the two one right and then
they get the ball back and they go right
down the field again touchdown Christian
McCaffrey play 75-yard Drive 20 plus
yards screen right and they get it done
they caught way that was that the one he
threw there's a little swing pass out to
the right then it was a pass yep big
screen and then the pass interference in
the end zone and they punched right
eight Thrive five plays 75 yards
touchdown
27:20 right that was
the 60 yard run by Christian McCaffrey
on the first play of that exactly and
then the ninth drive was go down there
and they missed a field goal and they
moved the ball easily on that try he did
DJ more of the hold try right so that
was one of the more impressive offensive
performances I've seen all year and
there they were in a moment of the game
yeah they could have 44 I mean where I
just like wow I mean I eat so when you
watch film and of course I knew what the
game went but you look up and you go
yeah I'm gonna look at the scoreboard
here as I'm watching a film that's gonna
say 22 3 whoa it's 3 2 3 whoa it's 10 to
10 I mean that was unbelievable in
itself then you flip it over to the
other side and I mean Seattle really did
nothing schematically to help it was a
true game of the jimmies and the Joe's
beat the X's in the O's I mean it was
Russell Wilson Tyler Lockett David Moore
and Moore and Chris Carr st. Chris
Carson they just made some plays and
some really huge moments there was never
really a play all game long on Seattle's
offense where I said oh the scheme got
him open it was know this guy beat the
man man-to-man on a route yeah a Russell
bite bought time and made a little
shroud over a guy exactly right and run
over exactly right so from a team on
team aspect Carolina won the battle in a
big way but Russell Wilson's ability and
then some of the clutch nough some of
the defensive players in those big
situations where there was Nasir Jones
busting through the line or Bobby Wagner
making a big tackle Seattle pirates just
made big plays and some big moments and
that was really all that boils down to
that's how you feel that's how I feel I
mean I I don't come away from that game
going oh I feel much better about
Seattle I still like Seattle but I still
have questions their defense is not
special I leave Carolina going damn this
is the second week in a row you guys
found a way to lose I mean they let that
Thursday night blowout against the
Pittsburgh Steelers just snowball to
three in a row now you know where they
could have won a game last week in
Detroit that was a close football game
they messed up some situational football
on that missed the field goals I get
that this week they don't execute and
some sir
crucial situations as well and lose that
game and then ultimately what came back
to get Carolina is one of the weaknesses
we've always talked about with Carolina
they dominated literally every aspect of
the game except from one area that we
always kind of questioned and Dante
Jackson wasn't out there to play
yesterday he wasn't no they need another
true cover guy you know it's just when
David Moore or lock it or Baldwin
Seattle basically just said the hell
with their offense it's one-on-one
outside Russel throw piss missiles and
we'll catch him and that's really what
it came down to and then Wilson
I mean fourth and three bomb I mean I
couldn't believe it because third and
three he threw the bomb two more didn't
get it I went I can't believe he threw
that on third and three get the first
down fourth and three he threw it again
balls in the air and I go Josh what the
hell is he doing
can I go that was incredible credible
but man-to-man match up are the Seahawks
up do you believe that they're they
could go to the playoffs I do believe
they can go to the playoffs are they yes
and I want to make a real run in the
playoffs I don't expect that I will say
this we said if there's one team that
can exceed expectations yeah it's
Seattle because if everybody remembers
what the the talk was about them before
the year they lose a legion of boom or
old Thomas all that nonsense their
offensive lines gonna be awful they got
Brian Schottenheimer calling the place
right but you said they have Pete
Carroll yep they have also Wilson yeah
and they have a run game you're gonna
figure it out and when you look at
Seattle scheduled down the stretch it
gives you a lot of confidence compared
to everybody else right home against San
Francisco home against the Vikings at
San Francisco home against the Chiefs
home against the Cardinals yeah so four
out of your five or home yeah three of
those games are against three of the
worst teams the NFL's because they're in
your division the NFC West and you get
the Vikings and Chiefs at home right and
the Vikings they match up with really
well they're similar teams
really they're both lob it up to your
guide team exactly right and I trust
Russell Wilson more than I trust Curt
cousin I understand I trust the kicker
more right when I said Kansas City game
week 16 I mean they could get look on
Kansas City might be playing for nothing
I might say we don't even give a damn
you know now I also equally say that
to those points the Seattle could very
easily lose to the 49ers you know what I
mean
I don't expect them to but they don't
have a dominant defense or anything like
that this year and if their run game
doesn't work it does become Russell
Wilson Showtime what she's capable of
delivering more times than not but I
don't know if he will really be able to
do that against the NFL
only few little nuggets of news notes
before we get to lions bears yeah Andy
Dalton out for the year season-ending I
our thumb surgery the bit the Bengals
evaporated real quick I really started
like 5 to 9 5 & 3 I wonder if this will
be the end for him what yeah I'm just
saying I mean the end for him as a
starter involved in Cincinnati I am
getting to the point again where okay
it's been solid but are we just gonna
sit here in solid land forever or do we
want to go somewhere but doesn't that
start with Marvin yeah I'm not saying
him either I'm just trying to say I do
wonder about the future of Andy Dalton
with the bangles and where it goes from
here I get to look up his country at ya
know Jack Doyle expect to be put on IR
after an injury against the Dolphins and
then the only other thing is that the
NFL draft will air on ABC they'll show
all three days of the draft anchored by
the college gameday crew oh can I do a
little media stuff sure boy am I so
excited to hear who's the Michigan guy
Desmond Howard break down NFL scheme and
where guys are gonna fit like Kirk
Herbstreit is fine but these guys don't
understand the NFL it's you have Mel
Kiper for a reason yeah you have a guy
that studies this and knows this and
just give me Mel Kiper
and Luis Riddick and you know what it's
just a perfect example television
networks continue to do things that you
think you're going to like and you know
what you like you like Sims and love go
and Millar doing the draft and that's
what it'll be so screw these guys cuz
they're all bums well I'll say this like
I hear you I mean
Marib Street has a great feel for
college football it's gonna be able to
tell you about all these players we
think this is a very good host but
they're gonna tell me about how I know
you're right no coverage far beyond a
set with louis ridic a hundred percent
right about I don't care if what they're
like in college right you know why
because I I'm watching an ogre on on
Saturday night only wearing a headset
because people yell at him if he doesn't
wear a headset because all he does is
get the team around and go play harder
that's his only way that he coaches and
I and I go so you're gonna tell me that
LSU players who barely understand scheme
and don't understand coaching and they
always flourish in the NFL because they
have no coaching in college that you're
gonna give me a college expert that's
not gonna that's not gonna understand
that I agree I think the thing you said
this start was really one of the best
things about it that they're just gonna
repeat with the coaches say yeah what
happens in college football a little too
much for me
well I was talking to Urban Meyer well
guess what Urban Meyer is a liar so like
I don't really care what Orban Meyers is
unless you're watching the film and
speaking to NFL GM's I do not care if
you watch college football yeah all the
coaching staff he was always such a hard
worker okay Wow I know I know has been
making a case for Michigan still should
be ranked ahead a Notre Dame this year
before the Ohio State debacle I wanted
to be like remote what timeout does that
mean Lee Corso is gonna be telling me
about no I don't think so I don't think
the college game - maybe he's just gonna
put on the mascot hat for each pick the
Chargers victim I'm gonna put a bolt on
I'm getting real cocky now hey you are
coming it's only the number one pregame
show in all of sports in all of what
sport I don't know football which
football college but perfect it's
probably got better rays than any of the
NFL pregame show still have you seen
them go on that rant
how dare you speaking about my father
like that didn't say I was talking about
CBS why he's so sensitive it matched oh
quick stat about Christian McCaffrey
yeah I think this was from Sam Monson a
PFF he's played 97 percent of the
Panthers offensive snaps this sees right
todd gurley has played 84 this is insane
running back percentage uses out of
Christian McCaffrey yeah and to everyone
that said I don't know if he can handle
a load and running back he's handling a
load of a running back that we haven't
even seen before right he can run in the
tackles yeah he can run outside the
tackles he's the best mismatched
nightmare one of the best yeah he's in
he's in the car he's up there with the
Camaros and the Gurley sure that when
you split him out wide
yeah pray for your life exact you were a
linebacker you're done screen games
anything like that you're a hundred
percent I just thought that stat was
crazy it is crazy it really it's a
tribute to him it's a tribute to him not
only physically and what he doesn't take
care of his body but you know again it's
a tribute to him with what the great job
he does of not let letting have or
taking on too many car crash hit so I
think that's the thing you get a look at
bears played the Lions on Thursday right
and a lot of people went major abyss
keys out the Lions are gonna kick their
ass and I'm in a car with three of the
golf broadcasters and they're going oh
man I didn't know true Biscay wasn't
playing the lines are gonna win that one
and I said guys for most of these teams
the backup quarterback and the starting
quarterback there's not that much
different I said chase Daniel has been
in the system for five years he's going
to be fine and they were fine yeah but a
lot of people were leaving going what's
up with Stafford he looks awful right I
don't think it's crazy to say that this
is the worst season that Matt Stafford
has had maybe in his career there's no
doubt and I'm curious after you watch
the film yeah what the hell is happening
right now okay all right so let's just
start with a broad conversation of
what's going on I don't you know me I
don't give a damn what the stats say it
doesn't matter I mean it's about what's
there to be had I don't care if a guy
was five for 24 right if those 19
incompletions nobody's open I'm not
gonna sit there and go damn that
quarterback stinks how dare he couldn't
fit that ball into those covered guys
like glue I mean no I go damn oh and
those five passes did he give his team
the best chance to make a play did he
throw it exactly where he needed to was
at the right decision all those type of
things so I don't look at stats I don't
really give a damn about it
I dunno just from my general outlook of
the year that it is Matthew Stafford's
worst year of his career there's no
question about that and I'm just talking
about whether it's dumb interceptions or
Mis throws that I've seen him make where
I've gone what like he just threw that
sidearm 45 yards and here's the pockets
perfect and there's somebody 15 yards in
front of him wide open and he missed the
throw I don't get that or you know or
passes that are complete where the guy
has to fall down to get it he is off he
would be might here would be my first
overall assessment just of the season
and why he's off he has been like an
and1 mixtape at quarterback okay that's
what the that's what he's been asked to
play hey give me the Dipsy do dribble do
cross your ankles break your ankles flip
Beru pass and he's been that guard cool
just shotgun it and I'll get it done
guys I mean that's what he's been asked
to do with the quarterback situation
play street ball basically hey if you're
open shoot it man that's that's our only
rule if you're open you're shooting
that's this year that's what it's been
this whole career it's been it's been
it's been just hey getting the shotgun
we're gonna ride you if you're making
music few mistakes who cares
keep shooting keep throwing just gonna
be honest right I saw an ad one mixtape
tour and they were like oh you know what
the Dipsy dude I'm like man this thing
got corny no eights oh so that's the way
it's been it's been and one streetball
mixtape right they just drop back we
can't run weekly wide receivers and
we're gonna Theo Riddick out there
everybody just run through Ebron out
there and battle fines that I'll throw a
rifle around and yeah you know we'll
probably let up a touchdown on defense
but you'll get the ball back and we'll
ask you to do it yeah he's been now
they're going we want five passes on
every you're not allowed to shoot the
ball unless you have five I mean it's
like they're back to Hoosiers okay or
it's Chesky I mean whatever you want to
say now he's being asked to play this
structured game it's a culture shock it
is even for somebody as good as him and
has been around as long as him he's now
malicious saying I want to lean on my
defense and be some on the ball and I
want to play situational football the
correct way and that's it's a hard way
to play quarterback
especially when you've been just going
hey if I'm open I can shoot it right and
it goes yeah
now this coach is going no we want five
passes before you shoot anybody
what's the ball ball we want to run run
pass yeah we want to run run pass if
nothing's there don't take a chance are
defense'll I got a good scheme on this
end and we'll get the ball back and
you'll have another chance to execute
okay and I do think that's part of the
struggles you're seeing for Matthew
Stafford it's a true truly one of the
biggest cultural changes that any
players had to go through as I was
thinking about this over the last like
24 hours really there's really not I
still see people listing Jim Bob cooter
as a head coaching yeah that's insane
that is insane I mean so to add to the
conversation of this hey it's great they
have a little bit better old wine this
year again it's a better old line this
is still the same old wine they lit up
10 sacks three weeks ago against the
Minnesota Vikings you know just because
you know okay just because there wasn't
a ton of sacks in the game the other day
he was under pressure a lot Colio mac
pushed his guy back into his face and in
the pocket a lot and added to that their
best players not playing carry on
Johnson wasn't out there Oh Kevin Jones
is out for the year Marvin Jones is the
only guy to really be scared of of a big
play on that team
not even can he go he is not
kenny-dowall day is really good i if you
and me watched film I just go I would go
tell me when Kenny gala day is really
open he makes some great catches when
he's contested but he's not open Marvin
Jones gets Marvin Jones at least can
take that run by people so Gallagher
holidays were a lob bomb he's more of a
yes covered he's physical presence over
the middle he might break an arm tackle
he's a really good player I'm not trying
to downgrade him but he's not a guy
where defenses are going damn if we
don't double gala day or put our best
corner on him we're screwed this week so
there's not a lot of help around him
okay I mean they went into that game
with gala day and TJ Jones and I can't
even remember Bruce Ellington career
journeyman oh my why couldn't they move
the ball but a great defensive football
but Chris Bruce on to play basketball
South Carolina - yeah so you know again
it's a bad year it's a cultural change
I'd really
you think he's going through this hey in
my mind he's put enough money in the
bank to earn himself one year of being
somewhat of a [ __ ] so you're buried
this team your big thing is for almost a
decade right it was Matt Stafford score
as many points as you can and in a time
in which his wide receiving core is
decimated his starting running back his
gone right and he's with an offensive
coordinator that's not that imaginative
he also as a head coach that's going
don't throw as much right don't even
take a chance on this rat if you see
that I know that you're crazy Stafford
right we're gonna change who you are
so all of that's happening at the same
time yes that's my take I don't know
that but I'm just telling you as a
quarterback I know in my career when I
got around Josh McDaniels
in Denver I learned things that I had
never learned before and I certainly
wasn't Matt Stafford and yeah I think
it's just a total change of pace he's
gone from being the Golden State
Warriors on that offense right to now
he's with the 1993 Knicks and Pat Riley
and they threw the post we were scoring
1:30 a game and now we're scoring 74
yeah and you're gonna like right we're
gonna hold them to 72 exactly that's
what he's being asked to do that game
played out perfectly just so everybody
knows that there that was as good as the
Lions could do in that game he threw a
bad pick they blitzed him he tried to
throw a hot route and he Jackson made a
play hey they get players to they get
paid over there and Chicago last time I
checked and he made a bad pick that was
it someone said this online I can't
remember - and I apologized for stealing
their stuff but everyone is saying that
Aaron Donald is the clear-cut favorite
for a defensive player of the year the
last offensive back to win Defensive
Player of the Year was 2010 Troy
Polamalu yeah 63 tackles one sack seven
interceptions one forced fumble one
touchdown right Eddie Jackson has 38
tackles one sack two forced fumbles four
interceptions and three touched a
special he's a special player he's got a
great knack for everything should he be
in the mention for Defensive Player of
the Year I mean no he'll be one of the
three guys that gets on the screen with
Aaron may be exactly right I mean first
of all there's he's not even gonna be
the league guy on his own defense
52s going there right okay he's really
good I mean their whole defense is
really good but I can just tell you from
playing Troy Polamalu and preparing for
him whether it was a starter or a backup
it's a very special individual and what
they the greatness of those Steelers
defenses a lot were because of what
Polamalu could do and bring to the game
plan on a weekly basis Eddie Jackson's
just playing his role and he does well
he's not the game changer of Polamalu
was but regardless those stats are
actually very impressive I didn't write
so let's do great moments in gambling
this week with Adam Lefko and we're
gonna start off both of us got lucky
with the Patriots
I don't know if you guys saw this
Patriots were up 14 I took the Patriots
we both did
the law I had a root for you did not win
the Patriots right Patriots were favored
by nine and a half Jets with like two
minutes left
drive down first and tenth first and
goal inside the five and the Patriots
top him four plays in a row if they
scored it would have made it seven
Patriots got the stop and they cover the
spread great moment in gambling how much
money did you have on that one like 300
damn that's why I was rooting for the
jugular this one I was scared
Simms went with the Raiders I went with
the Ravens Ravens were favored by 10 and
a half and they're up third they're up I
want to feel good about it a toppling 27
to 17
late in the fourth they're up 10 and I'm
sitting there and I'm going the Ravens
aren't gonna go down and score again
they've already gotten one of their
scores on a punt return so the offense
really wasn't that great and I'm going
damn it they're gonna win this game by
10 well what do you know
Terrell's fumble recovery for a
touchdown they go up 34 to 17 and that
is a great moment in gambling but it was
also bad for you
yeah but it's one of those games it's
one of those plays where the common fans
going oh that ice did you have no idea
that just swung millions of dollars
because of that play yeah Thursday yeah
Falcons Saints
sym said i don't think that the Saints
can win by 13 Adam said bet your ass
they can and I'll say the big play on
that fourth quarter
Calvin ready hit across the middle he's
going to the endzone mark Latimer
punches the ball out fumbles they were
up 14 it kept it at 14 and the Saints
held on a great montage in left calmly I
got very lucky this week so then what
I'm saying is it's like the weeks going
forward you're gonna realize you're
gonna get lucky of course I am
I'd know that Bears lying they fumble
three times inside the 20-yard line
I was now Julio and then Matt Ryan right
Falcons were yeah I was I was like in a
tryptophan tequila trance at that point
yeah I just had to research my brain for
that bears Lions right both of us took
the Bears - three and a half oh yeah
it's 1616 and there's the Pick six by
Eddie Jack's a.m. but hold on
not so fast the Lions are driving down
less than two minutes left and Stafford
throws another interception keeping it
at six or at seven and covering the
spread we got lucky there a great one
yeah but I'm ending it with one that we
didn't get so lucky the wash the Dallas
Cowboys are up 31 to 20 right which
means they're up 11 right and they're
favored by seven and a half we both took
Washington to cover the seven and a half
if Washington kicks a field goal were
screwed yeah because if it gets to eight
it's over right we need to get the
touchdown across the middle third and
five Jordan Reed hit at the 11 face to
face no penalty amazing it wasn't called
unbelievable and they'd settle for a
field goal and we both lose they lose by
eight right and the line was seven and a
half you took a beating you had 300 on
Washington yep that hurt me but those
are five plays I'll show you don't
gamble the game is in the balance and
you're relying on a fumble return for a
win
goal-line stand you're freaking out
about a penalty that's not cold a
goal-line fumble by Calvin Ridley an
interception and that's gamble yeah that
is game but isn't that crazy it's worse
than ever now in the NFL it's worse than
ever I would think you know the offense
is never out of a game you know just
it's it's what about I actually sat
there knowing that situation with the
Redskins game of course rooting for the
score cuz I want to get my bleacher
dollars but at the same time when they
didn't call the penalty I was a very big
part of me that was very happy about
that
that shit's got to end oh the automatic
penalty yeah but that one was blatant
III was face you know the quarterbacks
got to start taking a blame for getting
his guy's head torn off there used to be
a day and age where the quarterback
would feel guilty when his guy got
knocked out and they had to put him out
in a paddy wagon like now it's just like
ah screw up put him on the paddy wagon
get the next guy they're free 15 yards
right [ __ ] his concussion rate we want
to keep playing
I will not issue with the NFL right now
in general it's my number one problem
his quarterbacks not caring about all
that and there's there's no game out of
reach like I've read these articles last
week oh the NFL scoring is up passing
yardage is up the closeness of the games
in the fourth quarter it's never been so
close of course it's always gonna be
that way have you not watched the big 12
football it's gonna be the same thing in
the NFL I mean quarterback throws the
ball in the triple coverage pass
interference defense 33 yards
quarterbacks got pressure in completion
Oh somebody touched his neck 15 yards
too hard of a hit on the quarterback
quarterback throws the ball down the
middle of the field shouldn't do it
receivers gonna get decapitated who
cares
15 yards unnecessary roughness games are
going to be closed because of that
that's why I just think we got to be
careful where we go in the NFL the game
could have been closed right if a Maury
Cooper didn't go off for like a honey
yards rush was even right I heard
someone talking about that Jon Gruden is
not able to communicate with Amari
Cooper but Garrett can mmm because
Garret is welcoming and he's supportive
and he's the clapper and he's gonna sit
down with him or he's got a great way
about it you're the man Amari right we
need you Amari right he's a chef ski
he's not gonna put any pressure at
pressure on what I mean by chefs key is
when we hung out with Garrett that one
time he spent a good part of the summer
meeting with Coach K with Roma and going
how do you communicate with athletes
Gruden is still running 1997 exactly
Jayson Garrett's trying to go Zeke it's
okay if your party buddy yes give me the
goods
I saw amore look in the camera and talk
trash
I saw a Mori Cooper on the bench during
the game with Cole Beasley laughing I
never saw that no never saw it I know
how much more viable is this Cowboys
team now with Amari Cooper at least they
got the formula that we know and we've
talked about over the last four years a
guy that can take a slant and go that's
right I mean it's back to you know Romo
Dez Bryant DeMarco Murray or Ezekiel
Elliott Dez Bryant you know dak Prescott
whatever year you want to choose but
that was the formula and I mean yeah
those were special plays it shows you
that scenery change can help players
right getting around the new whatever it
is theme song new theme within the
organization just having a few coaching
points set a different way to you and
you go oh that makes sense to me okay so
that's what I need to do you know just
being around coaches that you feel like
have confidence in you as opposed the
last place where they're you know like
you're saying who knows not
communicating well are constantly
putting pressure on them whatever it may
be but we see it a lot where guys change
places and then become better player
than where they were so there is some
truth of that but man the Seattle I mean
the Cowboys I mean there was I looked at
their ballers balled out in the most big
big moments the two plays for Amari
Cooper came in back-to-back drives then
the subsequent Drive after that was
thoughtful sack fumble DeMarcus Lawrence
followed by the great dak Prescott run
housing and that really won the game for
them at the end of the day yeah yeah it
was a force the whole time the whole
time mark Columbia ain't that we were
right about them yeah we were right I
mean they were spot-on
and I did not think you were gonna paint
the Cowboys before the year but yeah
they were they're good they're you have
a lot of talent they don't need us they
don't need a complicated formula their
defense just kind of beat you up I think
pal
Cooper can take it up with man-on-man
right after I'm mad at myself to
self-evaluate myself on that bet
I go Thanksgiving week making your first
start don't bet on a quarterback in that
scenario he's not getting any real reps
he's gonna walk through reps just
different he threw some helicopters out
there in the game who colt yeah there
was two of those interceptions were very
bad um
I think that of all the teams in the NFL
one team had a perfect week and that was
the Patriots Patriots beat the Jets did
not play at their best but still won by
double digits right Steelers lose to the
Denver Broncos so they lose to a team
that's not even the playoff race and
they were competing for a bye Chiefs
lose to the Rams on Monday night Melvin
Gordon suffers an MCL sprain for the
Chargers and now he's gonna be hobbled
for the next few weeks and they got to
arrest them so they're not gonna be
ready to go competing for a top two seed
the Patriots are now firmly in the
number-2 spot and only one game back of
the Chiefs yeah
the team that they beat right Chiefs
could easily lose one more game the
Patriots we were talking about earlier
oh man they're gonna have to play on the
road in the playoffs first time in a
long time they might not even get a bye
and in one week
yeah they're sniffing the ones right I
mean they won what was it seven in a row
or six in a row and we all like gave up
on them for the Tennessee Titan game but
I would like to I mean we did we did not
well we tried to talk sense into people
by going their best so linemen Shaq
Mason who's one of the best guards in
football especially in the run game he
wasn't playing
Sonne Michelle wasn't playing or if he
was he was less than a hundred percent
Trent Brown got hurt oh and the greatest
tight end in the history of the sport
wasn't playing I mean he's back and not
only is he awesome in the pass game but
you know we always talked about his
ability to block in the run game you
know that they're they have a special
formula on which they play they're cool
to watch I enjoy watching the Patriots
this year this I formation smash your
face and run game so I wrote it down
that Tom looked crisp yesterday yes he
did
Josh Gordon's the clear number one yeah
like every time there's a big processor
oh yeah they do he's looking at Josh
Gordon right
Sony Michele's ability to just slash up
the gut really quick it's an element
that I haven't seen to them before yeah
and it truly allows James White to be
the off pace guy right but Edelman and
Gordon crossers with Gronk up the middle
pick your poison I don't know what
you're gonna do
I know cross layers and the NFL are the
easiest way to steal yards and football
right now I don't know why teams don't
run multiple crossers every drive
everybody wants to put all these people
at the line of scrimmage to stop read
option and stretch sweep and all these
things and I watch film on TV I'm on
every week and in fact I'm gonna show
you this cuz I did this today here we go
here's Panthers Seahawks D just read
that line right at the top one know that
you think of something deep crossers
open every time all over NFL one two
three four five underlines it's
everywhere it's constant and I go man
that team just threw a deep crosser for
25 yards and they don't call the play
again for like six more series and I go
why I don't understand well like Rams
Chiefs Saints Patriots they'll just beat
you to death with it they'll go away you
didn't cover it no to plays we'll call
it again okay you still didn't cover it
three more if we're coming back with it
again but yeah I mean it was a big week
for the page big week back to a point
yeah Steelers lose yeah Big Ben
interception second week in a row the
last one got called back from a penalty
but Payton Steelers just had so many
mistakes the Xavier Grimble fumbled to
the end zone
the James Connor fumble when they're
driving down there to pretty much win
the game just a lot of the big bend's
interceptions were just blocked field
goal blocked field goal missed wide open
passes Steelers are just a different
team on the road they just they had they
they screwed it up they're there they're
gonna be like worse than the Carolina
Panthers today and go back and go damn
how did we lose that game meanwhile the
Broncos in back-to-back weeks have
beaten the Chargers and the Steelers
yeah and our five and six and somehow
alive right I mean
lost to the Rams and the Chiefs twice
the toughest schedule in football maybe
they should have you know that's it's
brutal but yeah I mean the Steelers they
don't I didn't come away that game
feeling okay great it was the Broncos
one I know the Broncos are talented
didn't make me feel any better about the
Broncos or worse about the Steelers
other than that you know the Steelers
again in situational football you okay
they don't not for the year and I was
like holy crap I think you're like
getting lightheaded or something um but
to scare the crap out of me but the the
end of the game again it was that not
eerie similar to like patriot game last
year over the middle throw that gets
intercepted like so many things I have
issues with that end of the game first
of all run the ball there run the ball
one more time don't give Denver the
chance to have the ball and go down and
kick a game-tying for a game-winning
field goal at that point don't do that
they had no timeouts so run it again
second thing is they're not an RPO team
they don't do rpoS but now you're gonna
do it on the biggest play of the game
over the middle and then fumble the snap
and the exertion you've never done it
and then try to throw it over the middle
and it was bouncy dominated at Shelby
Harris that's why he was back there I
mean he wasn't dropping into coverage he
dominated her telling me that the
interception happened because Pouncy
blocked too well he blocked well and
Shelby gave up and was just basically
like okay I'm done and then he saw he
was about to throw and he said [ __ ] on
me get in the passing lane and hit him
in the chest Wow but regardless was
gonna be picked by Bradley Roby anyways
I mean to me that's where like they just
got to fine-tune some of them maybe they
didn't have confidence in Connor there I
don't know what it means I mean it's you
know James he that fumble was huge he
had the drop pass last week in Great
Alaska he is not he's not let me on bail
um but I also look at Big Ben in that
situation just go man you played too
much football in too many big moments to
even let that one go yeah like just
throw it onto the back of the end zone
then we're just run forward or just go
forward exactly where I take a sack
whatever it may be I think Juju's faster
than Antonio Brown I I don't think
arounds taken 297 yard touchdowns it's I
I agree with you it's close juju is
deceiving because he's a strong powerful
runner that run and then just stiff arm
one guy into the other guy she's just
one of those guys right I mean you've
seen them in person
yeah the uniform does not do him justice
he's a much bigger man I was like oh
he's big and I didn't appreciate how big
he was until I met like Stefon Diggs
yeah and then I was like Oh Jude is a
lot bigger than you right I almost had
to meet other wide receivers which means
when I meet Julio yeah I'm gonna be like
holy crap right like Oh Doug like you're
so tiny
yeah there is a chance that Eric Barry
could be coming back soon they need him
how big of a deal would that be if he
was at like 90% huge I mean it's their
biggest issue with their team it's
through it's why I can't really against
any of the quality teams and football is
hard for me to pick Kansas City just
it's just a hard way to win to think
your offense has to outscore all the
time your defense is never gonna make a
stop at any crucial point one guy could
do that much at least he gives it one
more down the pecking order for some
lesser matchups to worry about whether
there has to be a Gronk him verse Gronk
or whatever it may be poking on scanned
records right it's just there so you
know to me again they'd be a team I'd be
looking at Pacman Jones if I'm them yeah
why did the Broncos cut him I don't know
I don't have the the the story there I
mean you know I will get it um you know
pac-man and some of his friends were the
first to let me know that he was going
to be released yeah but I don't know the
story of that the story came out on
Sunday that Hugh Jackson might be the
next coach of the Bengals and I laughed
so loud yeah you should have how the
hell is this even a thing I don't know
what's I really don't know I can't I
don't even know but they're I I mean
they can't be that stupid Marvin Lewis
for 16 years
gosh well Marvin looks like Bill
Belichick compared to Hugh Van Dam I
mean Hugh's it's just no is so
embarrassing
like I'm just gonna say like be
on the fact that he's lost like 50 games
in the three years or whatever it was or
four years he's got like three wins
beyond the fact that he's like on the
field trying to DAP up all of his former
players and getting stopped by Baker
Mayfield beyond the fact that like he's
like lied in the media and tried to
cover things up beyond the fact that
he's like had public squabbles with
coaching staffs and so many people have
come forward like all of that and you
faced him twice a year and you go he's
the guy yeah I know I don't get that
either
Marvin should not get a say for the next
coach this is not Bill Belichick right
he has not won a playoff game in 16
years the current I don't even know who
the GM is it's her owner Mike Brown is
that how it works or is that Marvin
Lewis yeah it's a little bit of both
that's a franchise where I go you're
stuck until your owners gone yeah you
just are because they've been running it
like a small town team yeah you don't
have any infrastructure for success
Marvin Lewis doesn't get to pick his
successor he hasn't been successful
enough to pick a successor right they
just need to blow the whole thing up but
that's been the story for six years yeah
I know I know I think this is a year
it's finally gonna be over that's what
we said last I know I was shocked too I
will say is interesting it was good at
evaluating talent I was that I was just
gonna go into Baker Mayfield and what a
baller he is okay I mean he's just a
baller and you know what I respect his
attitude towards Hugh Jackson towards
the end to like I understand it is a
business and things change and all that
but as you heard me say a little earlier
today too
like you can't win as a pro athlete
sometimes they're okay yeah he's
competitive he's not gonna be nice to
the opposing coach who just left their
team to go help out the division rival
that they still have to apply two more
times he's not cool with that
oh he cares you know but yet if he
didn't care it would be I call what's
wrong with these pro athletes they don't
care about anything they just want to go
out and collect checks no we [ __ ]
cares let's see if I was a Browns fan of
my quarterback said that's a rivalry
game this is how long we look at yeah
right right
you would love it right exactly I mean
it's just he's yeah everybody taken the
side of Hugh Jackson that like the man's
got a the man's got to get a job
wherever he could he was also being paid
not to work exactly right so it's not
like this man's like starving yes and I
know that everyone likes you
yeah it does seem like in the media
everyone likes to stick up for Hugh yeah
they do but no I asked you earlier if
Jon Gruden left got if Jon Gruden got
fired right and then went and and joined
the Panthers two weeks later yeah and
then played you the week after that you
wouldn't like no I would not I bet
that's kind of kind of unethical it's
kind of [ __ ] up gonna leave us and now
what go and tell them all our secrets
like he was just telling us to buy into
everything he said you know 14 days ago
now he's gonna go in and tell everybody
what we what he said to us and that's
what Baker is like oh yeah Baker you
know what when you think somebody is
fake yeah and then they do something
then you think they're fake exactly when
Baker was comment on people's instagrams
today and he was fake yeah he believes a
Hugh Jackson was a liar yeah and the
whole thing with Tyrod Taylor I'm sure
that Baker watched that went man I never
had a chance to start right right he was
gonna start Tyrod from the get-go yeah
and then he went out there and since
Hugh's been gone nine touchdowns one
interception yeah and he's won more
games since he's been gone than Hugh one
nearly the entire time he was there yeah
I know
and so Baker's looking at going and you
know what I do like big I did too that's
not what's there not to like I mean it's
this he's he's what you want
he balls he's not afraid to call people
out right yeah I dig it I'm not sitting
here I can't sit here and take the side
of Hugh Jackson oh I'm sorry yeah I'm
with you you know totally with you well
but there was that one time that we
shared a Cabernet I don't really care
it's why I tell you guys I don't want to
meet any of these people so I can just
[ __ ] all over yeah apparently the
Dolphins haven't seen Andrew Luck play
in Indianapolis before running the ball
on third and 10 to series and resume
yeah see that story before that when
Andrew Luck gets the ball last he wins
and Indianapolis that was hilarious to
me out of gas on the hot seat I mean he
probably is we got to give Phillip
Rivers some kudos I mean 25 completions
in a row 28 of 29 that's insane okay I
don't give a damn if it's the car
Arizona's defense is not that bad
I mean Kim D Chi had two and a half
sacks in the first half the disaster of
which is the 49ers yeah what's going on
there well I mean I don't know you know
as much as I do I did it sound like I
called Kyle yesterday I was like hey
what's going on with your dysfunctional
linebacker who's getting arrested in the
team l'hotel I guess John Lynch didn't
fleece Ryan pace with that trade huh to
get Solomon Tommy I would say not and
then back up to get room of Auster right
no I mean that that's an that's annoying
I'm just trying to hit the all the NFL
if there's anybody else well there's one
that we need to talk up about yeah
Sunday Night Football yeah I guess Kirk
Cousins is a baller now that he want to
prime prime time Fowler it was night
time anyone night time he was like this
is a big one it's dark out the lights
are on
oh wait the lights are on at 4:25 too
but I got to play bigger cuz everyone's
gonna judge me I didn't see those people
on Twitter even complimenting him either
the people that usually [ __ ] oh oh they
never do I mean that's that's what they
that's why I don't I can't even deal
with Twitter I don't care I just don't
care that no one on Twitter's ever been
wrong ever in their lives it reminds me
of somebody else in our world Aaron
Rodgers yeah you said his mistakes are
magnified like no one else yeah I want
to first talk about how I'm seeing
people saying that Aaron Rodgers is
losing it and he's not that good he
missed that throw to Davante Adams and
people are saying Aaron Rodgers and that
good we're getting tweeted at from all
the morning shows right oh they're
saying Aaron Rodgers isn't that good oh
ah what's the Chris Sims official
response well I mean the official
response again is okay I mean we know my
issues with Mike McCarthy I mean again
that offense what they do its first and
second grade math I mean even compared
to the Vikings who are not reinventing
the wheel they're at least a mill school
math you know you got the Saints the
Patriots of rams those teams they're
running an advanced algebra right so
it's a joke of an offense they do
nothing okay you know we talked about oh
they got a run game when the running
back runs for more than 70 yards right
God they they got a run game I mean
that's how we talked about it there's
nothing there to help them out you know
in years past he
get them out of these situations more
because they could at least pass protect
as a no line they were a great pass
protecting Oh line so that would give
him time left go as you and I saw so
many times on Sundays together at least
the time to dance around and then wait
for receivers to get open now I saw him
throw a few balls down the middle of the
field the Jimmy Graham that Gronkowski
caught for Brady yesterday Jimmy Graham
does never seem to come up with them I
don't I mean again Davante Adams is a
good player he's not a superstar
receiver I mean there's no double
teaming Davante Adams you know they
don't even put Xavier Rhodes on him
every time they play man it wasn't like
they were like man Xavier has to be on
him or we're screwed he played him a lot
are we gonna do you're gonna start
telling me economists ain't Brown now is
a huge threat in the past game I mean so
again what's there to really look at I
don't know what else to say it's almost
like the Blake bortles conversation I'm
so sick of it and like I've just said it
so many millions of times
that I don't know what to say I didn't
think they would win in any chance last
night I picked the Vikings I never even
doubted that game uh in our bets you
picked the Packers to cover right right
but I picked the Vikings to win the game
Nick if you could make sure that was the
spread pewter audio is three and a half
for Minnesota right that was another
game Minnesota decided not to kick the
field goal yeah to go up ten or no they
would have gone up what was at a time
thirteen thirteen I was done I was like
and I was like take the points because
then I'm definitely gonna cover the
spread but luckily Aaron Rodgers
couldn't I mean they'll be able to fall
back the fact that Bailey missed two
field goals right right
Bailey missed two field goals there was
a one extra point one oh yeah - so I
understand that but still like the logic
I heard with like oh I mean oh we want
to go you want to go up thirteen yes I
don't understand that you want to make
Rodgers water first down a touch install
the clock yeah I thought it was
unnecessary right I have another theory
yeah and it starts with what Aaron
Rodgers said post game right from some
teams
and then we got to take care of our own
business you know we have to find a way
to win a game on the road or Owen six on
the road but this is where we just gotta
go back home get some rest
beat Arizona and then come back and beat
Atlanta and go to Chicago a place we've
won number of times beat them go to New
York around Christmas beat them then
come home and come home and be Detroit I
have a theory
this is the 2018 relax instead of our e
lax its beat the Cardinals beat the
Falcons beat the Bears beat the Jets
beat the Lions
I believe that Aaron Rodgers wanted to
start off for six and one everybody is
willing to part with Mike McCarthy so he
didn't carry them to a seven seven and
one and let people think that they have
a chance to keep their jobs they know
there's nothing there Aaron Rodgers
after the game is about to go John wick
he just named all of his future victims
the Cardinals the Falcons the Bears Jets
Aaron is about to go on a five-week
spree Aaron Rodgers just gave us the
blueprint when does a quarterback ever
talk about the next week let alone the
next five yeah here yeah Aaron's about
to go nuts it'll be next level I'm not
just gonna tell you cuz I don't believe
it and you know me I'm fan number one
you just move down to number two
the past protection is an issue right so
that to me is a huge reason to why he
can't take over games even with the lack
of talent around him you know again I'd
like to remind everybody the offense is
not special I mean listen when they
throw a screen pass and it goes for ten
yards I'm like whoa that was pretty good
I mean they have three or four game plan
plays a game and I want to be a good job
but now you only need 45 more and it'll
be you'll have it real offense you know
I don't know what else to say their
defense is falling apart their best
player is not out there Mike Daniels I
mean their best player on defenses of
rookie number 23 JR Alexander I mean
there's nothing there's nothing to the
team is what I'm trying to tell
everybody there's nothing and if you
think oh man Aaron Rodgers is having a
bad year Aaron Rodgers has thrown four
more yards than Drew Brees he's thrown
four less touchdowns he's also thrown
only one interception
yeah sure Brees has two and he's been
sacked 24 more times so he's under
pressure constant right for the guy
who's about as mobile as they get in
football and I know some of those sacks
happen when his knee was hurt but this
is one of the greatest in the pocket
dancers and the history of the sport
so the baddest percentages are down
because how many times last night did we
see him have to dance around and avoid
getting sacked and throw it away right
left go oh the completion shocked I'm
really shocked really shocked yeah um
alright so Rodgers was playing like [ __ ]
I just hope everybody knows I would tell
them you can count on me for that I
don't give a damn if my dad was out
there playing like [ __ ] I'd say he's
shitty right now they need to sit him I
just I don't know what else to say Aaron
Rodgers did talk about Patrick mahomes
and said I don't want to respect
disrespect him with this but I see a lot
of my young self in him rolls around
runs around make plays he's got a big
Army's talented plays with a great
swagger he's fun to watch yeah love that
fan question for you this is from seed
illionaire Niners offense not looking
great is Shanahan pulling his punches
this year until he has his offensive
weapons back so other teams don't have
his good stuff on film no no definitely
not with guys like that they always let
it go because they always feel like
their offenses
gonna grow I'm gonna have more wrinkles
new things I can do the next year
whatever they don't think like that he's
got you know a quarterback issue he's
got a lack of weapons on the receiver
issue you know I mean when there's no
Marquis Goodwin out there there's nobody
that scares you it remotely at all on
that offense yet and their deepness lets
up too many big plays but no I mean I
think really the biggest problem with
Kyle and the 49ers is you know they
don't have a backup quarterback for one
that would be my first thing I'm not
trying to be a jerk but CJ Beathard was
as Lefko would tell you from the day
they drafted him I was like damn I don't
know it may be the end of the six
rounder to me seventh round her
undrafted free agent so guys like
Beathard and Nick Mullens are to me like
borderline third sring us in the NFL and
we're seeing that that if the game can't
just be served up on a silver platter
for them perfectly like it wasn't
Oakland on the Thursday night game when
they blew them out and everyone wanted
to say Nick Mullins was Brett Favre yes
what the problem is when those plays
aren't there to be had just these easy
plays that the game plan provides you
know you need talent there you need
talent at the quarterback position it
can't always be on the OC to come up
with a perfect play um alright so I love
you I love you a pleasure to come back
and see you I'm glad you're back with
your favorite lefty yeah four oh yeah
that's right I went from the lefty to
you foursome peace out homies vendrick
would say good evening and for the lef
koe man we will holla holla holla at you
later we'll be back with some film on
Wednesday big film will join us and
Thursday we'll see if Sims can narrow
the lead or Adam is gonna run away with
vinegar and a big lead now
you